today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
it's that time of year
always
and you guys have been waiting and we
are happy to let you know that the new
i'm upstairs
merch collection
is available now at
theovonstore.com the greatest excuse on
earth
if you need something
wish i could help baby but i'm upstairs
if you need me
you know where i'm at
theovonstore.com thank you guys for all
your love and support
today's guest is the owner of hazard
mill farms
and he farms roughly 75 000 birds a year
getting them out the door
and on to the dinner
he's a second generation turkey farmer
here in the united states of america
we're happy to have that bird man with
us today
turkey farmer robert
hupman
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
just
robert huffman we're sitting here with
uh the turkey farmer baby this is your
time of year really coming up yeah yeah
we generally uh it's kind of funny we we
get that a lot but uh we're year-round
you know so thanksgiving is just another
another day for us we're we're pumping
turkeys you know 24 7. oh dang man but
do people i feel like people like i feel
do you wake up on thanksgiving morning
and you're like fired up and the kids
are all you know you know they're fired
up and people are doing like
turkey calls like is it that kind of a
day for you guys is it how how big of a
of this time of year is uh y'all's
market share basically
uh for for our market share it's
probably
i don't know maybe i don't know what
market share means yeah so so generally
we're growing birds year round so if my
flock happens to go out before
thanksgiving or month before fine if it
doesn't um
it's probably about
i don't know 30 percent of what a true
turkey farm goes through because we're
pumping out we're selling breast meat
for you know lunch meat and other other
items that like that so i've had some i
mean i don't know if i've had you guys
how do i know if i've had you guys as
turkey uh most likely if you ever had a
deets and watson
sliced turkey that'd probably be one of
ours damn man thanks yeah i've loved it
we sent some stuff out used to when you
lived in l.a we said i think this
california buys some of our product as
well oh good yeah i probably enjoyed it
there
okay so for just a regular human right
i'm a human consumer
um
what part of the turkey is used for
uh like like
well i guess let me start here i'm just
trying to think of where to start with
like a turkey farmer like
you want a day in the life of a turkey
farmer like start to finish what i go
through yeah yeah what's like when you
get up in the morning like what does it
go like thank you so yeah so i'll wake
up i don't know why i'm here no you're
good thank you very much i've never been
good but that's sweet of you
um yeah robert so what is it like so you
start in the beginning of the day yeah
so normally i wake up 3 30 4 00 a.m
do a little paperwork knock some emails
out um go through the birds luckily
right now i got a full-time farmhand
this is the first time ever
so
i don't have to be up there as much but
we're going through them every day
you're checking for any type of
mortality making sure they all have
automatic feeders so there's one feed
line that runs continuously down the
barn 800 and some feet long so a feeder
that runs down the barn that they're all
housed in yep they're housed in it's uh
they have plenty of room ample mount we
you know biosecurity is key so we we
dress up suit up go through dip pans
make sure nothing comes in from the barn
that's not supposed to be in there oh
really yeah yeah we're very
to the next we do like animal welfare
every year you know we're really on top
of our game because you know this is our
livelihood this is why i feed my kid
right with
and you know some sometimes commercial
farms can
they'll call at commercial farms but
it's really just a small town guy you
know it's a family maybe running a dairy
operation maybe running cattle and then
they're also substituting some income
for other family members for for turkeys
okay so i can make the same i make the
same amount of money as if i was running
maybe 200 hit of cattle okay wow so with
the amount of turkeys you're running yes
and how many birds you guys uh
you know how many birds you guys dealing
with over there uh so roughly like 19
000 20 to 22 000 per flop and that's two
barns so
okay so 19 000 per flock so what does
that mean
so uh generally we have a flock and
it'll last uh 19 weeks as to a
full-grown bird and they go to market
okay okay and then uh depending how it
rotates you know you'll have like four
weeks down eight weeks down depending
when they're ready to place you with
more pulse or more turkeys from the
hatchery
okay so it starts with you get a batch
of turkeys yeah so you have no turkeys
at some point yeah yeah so sometimes
i'll have a down time for four weeks but
we're cleaning turkey [ __ ] okay so just
cleaning out the barns yeah yeah
so okay so
then you get the batch right yep
um
they come in fresh savings land you know
we spread out brand new shavings and
they're all shaved out yeah we cleaned
them out it's all nice nice clean pretty
pretty pretty ground strip club up in
there yeah nice nice lights
okay so you get them in and they are
they scared are they excited what do
they seem like they're ready to eat okay
so they've done travel got there they're
really happy birds they're clucking
they've been on the road yeah ready to
chill out yeah so we load them in they
come in
it's nice and warm in there for them
because when they're younger they like
it up you know around the 80s to 100
depending on the age of the bird okay so
you guys have lamps and stuff in there
they keep them warm heaters yeah we got
propane heaters
and uh so they're all in this hat and uh
at that point it's you already bought
them from a hatchery so they're all in
this barn yeah okay so you have them in
this barn now
how long until those birds
until you guys you know
you pull that card on them you know and
lowered them out and sent them on to the
market uh 19 18 and a half to 19 weeks
wow so they're and then when they go out
they're you know averaging 40 to 45
pounds okay how well the feed conversion
okay
so and that is you guys are feeding them
the whole time how often do you feed
them they eat non-stop they have that
they have access to water and food
the entire time
they're like my buddy corey dude
and will they eat uh
and what are they eating corn it's it's
a corn soybean and then sometimes wheat
and it's all natural
we have our own hatchery so y'all ever
go out there and give them a little
snack at night is there any kind of a
bedtime snack is there anything where
you're gonna sneak out there you're
feeling in a good mood you're going to
go out there and hook them up no there's
yeah like me you want moon pie but
they're like nah we're good so they just
like what they they're real no they
really just like that that feed that
corn soybean mix i mean
that's pretty much it they their water
we have a water system i mean they're
getting perfect ph every time okay so
like we're really really big on their
water so it's like a little spa in there
they treat you know they got the heat
going they got the food coming in
they're really living they're living
pretty large in there yeah okay curtains
go down they get natural light they get
to see outside a little bit i mean
they're
they're safe from any type of predators
sounds like a detox i went to one time
honestly be real honest yeah um now what
about this so so so then you go in there
on your daily routine you cruise in
there the cruise in there you have
special you know you got the gear on
because you don't want how detrimental
is it if you bring in something from the
outside world so just for instance
you've probably heard of avian flu oh
yeah yeah so like back uh
2016 15 and 16 they had a huge outbreak
killed a million plus birds nationwide
bam which it helped
yeah you're talking about it yeah yeah
so it you know we didn't luckily hit it
and i hate to prosper on you know bad
terms for other farmers because i hope
we all get our you know rightful do and
everybody be is successful um but it
helped us out and bumped us up real high
and uh
uh we did very well not having that
avian flu but it's literally if i went
outside stepped in some goose crap and
that fecal matter was on my shoe
if i stepped in that barn with the same
clothes i had on with that it would 100
affect the mortality rate no way within
like three days damn
so they're a real it's a real it's
almost like a
they sound like almost like a science ex
not a science experiment but they're
like a
real specific recipe if you put in a
little bit of something that's not good
it's going down yeah and then see like
absolutely real sensitive yeah so other
birds can affect other birds same like
you can't have chickens on a turkey farm
saying i can't have turkeys on chicken
farm stuff that would mess with a
chicken
will mess with a turkey oh really and it
won't won't seem like the geese that fly
you know they're they're just a carrier
they don't uh they don't die from the
avian flu but they can spread it to
other birds and even if say the damn
it's like succession have you seen that
show that's no no actually i haven't
it's like um
yeah it's like family members trying to
they're just not it's it's not just like
that but it's similar yeah it's just
like you know do the same breed you
think everybody be looking out for each
other you know if goose is gonna fly by
and get your intel or something drop a
note but instead yeah it's a family
right here the front guy almost looks
like he got a little gobble on him but
they uh they're all like rich people and
they're all like backstabbing but
they're all the same breed i did see the
first season now that you said that yeah
i gotta i i've just seen a little bit
but i gotta see some more but um
anyway so this is really cool so so now
you go in there you guys are kind of
like you you you're careful what you
bring into the barn yep and you get in
there it's it's the early morning and
then what are you guys doing at that
point so we're going through making sure
you know
none of the water lines are broke
there's no water leaks the feeds all
properly distributing through the lines
okay occasionally you'll have a
mortality one bird might just croak
from what could have been anything just
anything heart liver you know just
sometimes you just you know you have so
many birds in there well not so many but
you'll have birds in there and they just
you know just like human life man out
here though
no different if you were raising four
outside in the field you know oh you
could be jogging with your buddy just
drop yeah yeah same thing with those
dude
tom just dropped tom number two he's
like bro what's up
i ain't never saying something lose
something man and you don't know what's
going on they might have small beef
going on in there they you know occasion
they do fight you know they'll
occasionally rough up each other you
gotta break them up will they yeah yeah
dude like no nonsense keith peterson
maybe you got to get in there like her
um
okay so now you got the farm going
everything's going pretty swell yeah at
what point do you guys start to get them
ready for
the slaughter basically what do you call
it the
uh just uh
just harvest okay just kind of like uh
same as if you're harvesting corn just
for getting ready to
uh
it's uh i don't know just going out or
whatever birds go out that's kind of
what we okay we're going they're going
out we're we got a group coming in we
got a group going out yeah so it's a
nice way to say it they say it at senior
homes too a lot of times you know you
know don is going out yeah you know we
got a question that came in right here
for you robert
yep what up theo
turkey farmer how you doing
yeah i got a little question for you
uh so
i assume you're uh
taking these turkeys in
and you know you gotta kill em for meat
you know
are you the one who's doing these
killings how do you go do you just chop
its head off how do you go about this
is it peaceful is a long process and uh
do you ever uh develop some sort of
relationship with a certain turkey maybe
he does like a little dance or something
that you think is funny
and something unique about him that you
don't want to let him go you don't want
to send him off to some family for
dinner
so uh yeah have you ever kept one of
these turkeys for a prolonged period of
time
and that's about it that'll do it right
there for me theo
peace out gang brother i hope the guy's
clothed but he might not be you know
that's the world we live in man it's
just you know it is turkey farmer you're
interviewing that's a good point yeah
yeah i did it
i'd send in some i'd be naked too
if i'm talking to a bird man dude i'm
bringing my bird you know
um
so there you go that's a nice question
what would you say to that like when it
comes time to shut them down right
because you've got to do it it's got to
be done it's part of it so so that's
another aspect of the the farm
throughout there's birds that that need
to be cold
um either they get a broken wing broken
legs something happens they twist their
stuff up
you just gotta euthanize them you know
immediately because yeah we don't want
no bird to suffer while they're there we
don't if they can't get food water and
they can't properly move we just go
ahead and take them out
because what happens if a bird's in
there if a bird's in there and he can't
move then what's going on the other
birds will kill them
no way yeah but then we don't we don't
let that happen so and why do they do it
what's going on in there do you have any
intel it's just turkeys being turkeys
man in the real world man they don't
care they're yeah it's like damn sinaloa
yeah so that's why i was telling uh
spence over here that we uh
they're kind of like kids when they
first come in they're you know
loving they're happy
and then they turn into uh
teenage [ __ ] is trying to kill you
just like in jiu jitsu class little kids
start start cool and then next you know
they're over here beating up on old man
[Laughter]
okay wow so you got the birds now you
guys and when they when they when they
do to when they do send them out to
harvest when they send them out what's
the process do they line them all up and
like just neck them out now this will
this probably a little wild we'll bring
in
19 tractor trailers and hand load them
on three guys they'll bring them up it's
like a little escalator takes them right
up and they
pick one up put them in the cage load
the cage up truck goes down turns back
around they can load a truck up in like
35 minutes and they're gassing them well
they take them back to the processing
facility and that's they i think they
use like a co2 base and they'll just put
them to sleep then they're cutting them
up really sing them up conveyor belt so
they put the meat to they just put them
to sleep yeah so they're not shooting
them it's not like
anything no no yeah so like on the farm
they you got two options for your animal
welfare you can uh either they have like
a bolt gun like a cap gun you hit them
in the back of the head with it and i'll
just take them right out or some farmers
rig up like a little box with co2 and
they'll put them in and that way
they go night just go to sleep and then
you put them in the compost and then we
compost the birds for uh crop rotation
we'll put them on the fields and stuff
oh so they'll become a fertilizer almost
yeah we'll create fertilizer yep all
natural so you so you guys don't do the
actual uh
so the killing isn't actually known by
you guys it's shipped it's like
outsourced yeah so now so now i will
you know bugsy seagull out there just
rolls up huh yeah so we will kill birds
and ones i have to call i'll i'll pull
the meat out for friends and family cut
the breast me and i've got some pictures
i'll give you guys and you can show them
the size of the breast and stuff like
that but
damn yeah man constant okay so so we're
talking about the hip man the guy comes
in
the trucks come in we load them out at
night and then they uh
start to they go to the plant
they get uh you know processed up and
then they're out the door within like 24
to 48 hours so you don't see them back
you're not there putting them in the box
you're not there putting them in i'm
there i watch them go out make sure
everything runs smoothly on my end that
way the birds are you know safely loaded
yeah send them away because that's you
know that's our livelihood right yeah
that's the work i mean look that's what
it is i mean people love it i mean yeah
i mean i think people do anyway has the
has the turkey market have people been
buying less turkey over time what's
going on with turkey so turkey's like
influx so you'll get two years of like
markets up and it'll drops back down
then it'll go back up and generally
that's because when they go up
butterball and these bigger companies
will come in and be like we need to put
100 more houses across here so they'll
flood the market with turkey
then they'll sit there because we don't
freeze our birds our kid is out fresh
like what do you mean where they say we
need to like what do you mean that
they're just in the market when they
need to put more houses what do you mean
so they'll see the market value you know
turkey value go up and then what what
does it get to
you know
yeah like you breast meat might be four
something five something a pound
you know they really throw the or then
it'll be as low as a dollar when it
crashed because they'll have a lot of
birds frozen those bigger companies hold
that stuff oh i see yeah we really
specialize you know not only in just
turkey growth we were the first ones
doing antibiotic and organic turkeys we
have two different divisions and
we're considerably a small company
compared to cargill or pilgrim's pride
or tyson tyson's huge and butterball is
the biggest turkey company probably in
the world yeah
i used to watch uh
yeah i know i've had some butterball
before i'm sure
yeah i don't know if i liked it or not i
remember
now what about this guy is a question
right here this italian guy all right
what's up theo what's up turkey farmer
got a question man
what's up with the free range and the
natural and the
organic and the regular
is that just a farce
is it the real deal what are you buying
at the stores
thanks
that's that's a good question yeah it's
a great question man yeah what is it how
do they divide that up what do you guys
have to do do you guys have to so so if
it's a like the other farms are more
like the organic farms or the antibiotic
free that's uh
it's heavily regulated so you got a lot
more paperwork and actually like to be
an organic
turkey it has to come for organic
females so all those the closest organic
female to us i believe is in
pennsylvania so we have contract farms
npa
that grows grows that particular bird
okay so so a lot of what goes in i heard
this i have a friend that works for like
a meat company yeah called cow or
something i think
and uh but it's kow right and he sent me
some fancy meat one time and
it's good but
you know it's still expensive
but um
he was saying that what determines grass
fed it's just uh
it's certain like really regulations
don't even really have to do sometimes
with what they're eating it's just
sometimes where they live at things like
that
what uh so what's that like for you guys
so you have the different different
levels so like a uh au or whatever they
call it's antibiotic-free the only
difference in between that is if say a
bird gets like a common cold or
something you wouldn't be able to treat
it with like our pen or a penicillin for
like one or two days and everything's
done very properly with a vet you know
we have a vet that
checks the birds it's just a crazy uh
industry but they they make sure they've
really went and stepped
you know from what it used to be to now
it's it's by the book everything's clean
and done professionally but so was it it
used to be the used to be this the damn
dark art
from from what i hear back in we've been
doing it since 89 and it's been fairly
consistent all the way up just you know
more regulations and we we're wanting to
stay on top of everything yeah
but for like a free range bird
so all they'll do is they'll take my
barn build doors and then the doors will
open and then they can go out in a
fenced in area okay
sometimes they don't even go out like my
buddy grows uh free range they yeah they
free uh free-range chickens same thing
he spent all this money they leave the
doors open the birds are inside where
it's nice and safe anyway if it's sunny
they might come out for a little bit
check up and then they see a hawk or
something they'll i tell it back in yeah
maybe andy dufresne sneaks out at night
or one of them or one of them government
geese drop a turd down there
i'm just saying you think there'd be a
lot more of that madagascar type
activity you know somebody trying to
really uh put it throw a dirty spider in
charlotte's web out there you know but
um okay so what are the different types
of different varieties of turkey that's
for sale on the market you're just to
have the antibiotic free you're going to
have an organic bird a free range bird
and then
what they call a cage free bird which
snow bird
is caged up in a little cage that's just
a fake narrative that people create to
try to give people bad name farmers sure
and no bird is completely cage free
either like you gotta have some sort of
way to keep the bird or it could leave
right can turkeys leave well i mean i've
had it where uh they're smart enough to
turn the doorknob and whack it open with
their wing and actually try to make a
jailbreak everyone oh yeah man but
that's that's far few between that the
turkeys are in a wide open barn you know
you're looking at
one barns
40 000 square feet dang per barn
okay
so you guys get out there you got all
the turkeys they come in and they go out
um
and like so around thanksgiving like is
there an extra batch do you double up on
your batches like starting in like
october or something or you know would
you say it's not 19 weeks 19 weeks so
that's that's for a heavy tom and um if
if it's going for when we're doing like
turkeys for thanksgiving
they're probably they're probably
putting them in they're taking them out
at half that so they're probably going
out around 13 to 15 weeks with a
medium-sized bird okay and that's the
one that most people buy for yes that's
what they're going to buy for
thanksgiving and they'll put these
specialty birds just for that and
they're they're medium toms is what
they'll call them damn
yeah and how'd they get the name tom
it's genetically i guess that's what you
call you know
a tom and a hen and we'll have hens in
there occasionally because they'll sex
them but they don't always get them
right so you have big old hens
mixed in there with the tom is there
trans turkeys do you start to see that
even in like the turkey uh they don't
really identify other other than tom and
hen and
maybe you know you'll find a dominant
i found hens with beards on them maybe
they're maybe they're transitioning oh i
found some of them too around town
i've definitely dude one of my buddies
had a real issue with them
um
but he's doing good now i mean he's
doing pretty good anyway he's on like a
ranch right now in montana but um
the holidays are the most wonderful time
of the year it's a good time to to hug
somebody and to tickle somebody you
don't even know that well if you want
legally
and in a safe area
with more people shopping online every
year you gotta ship stuff man you gotta
damn get things out of your possession
and into somebody else's possession
even santa i heard a rumor some he's not
even going to some countries anymore
because of the crime and stuff and he's
going he's just going to ship stuff
there he's going to use ship station
ship station works with all major
carriers international and local
including fedex usps and ups
so not only is shipping easy you can
actually save money now that's something
no wonder 98 of companies that use ship
station for a year
keep using it for as long as they're in
business
it's that good
use my code theo to get a 60 day free
trial just enough time to handle the
holiday rush
just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top and enter code t-h-e-o
ship station make ship
happen
is there something interfering with your
happiness is there is there something
interfering with your happiness
and that's a question you have to ask
yourself
you have to ask yourself
is there something interfering with my
happiness
because when you get an answer if you
really make an honest answer then it's a
good place to start from to think about
stuff
and sometimes you can't think about
things alone
sometimes you need help
and i've gotten help from this company
betterhelp
i've gotten it over zoom over phone and
over uh s key payee
uh skype skype
skype
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
don't go it alone
try something different try something
new
better help might work for you
betterhelp.com
theo this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and tpw listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o it may be an option for you
what what's like the future of the
turkey business so
well let me think what i want to ask
right now so you got these different
types you got the males
so
can i eat a
male
turkey or a female turkey at
thanksgiving can i have either one yeah
potentially it might be either or so i
don't have any ideas no wow now my mom
know if it comes in the kitchen and
she's in there doing it yeah you would
never know really yeah
because uh so we sell turkey fries okay
and that's turkey nuts
so they're uh they're they have glands
and their nuts are actually in their
wings
no way yeah so they'll pop them things
out and you fry them up meet them up
they good or bad they're good they're
really good yeah i mean they're did they
bust a little or they just kind of now
they just fry them up it's just like you
know eating it yeah like a what this is
like a nugget like a chicken nugget you
got a little thing you get you eat
nuggets is this them right here
yeah wow yeah
yeah they're good man we've served them
at numerous meetings you know
congressmen and senators and stuff go to
the turkey federation meeting we used to
have them there
i mean i just ate elk nuts
like a week ago because we went out elk
hunting and our guide fixed up a nice uh
rocky mountain elk parmigiana
i think look yo rogan can apparently eat
his own penis i read the other day on
the internet so i think at this point
everything's
everything's fair game dude if i was
starving i'd eat one of my nuts right
out of my damn body i think you know
because if they feel it feels like you'd
have to heal up good good oh yeah i'd
have one i'm gonna have both of them
like some creep you know damn but um
okay so
do why does turkey look so ugly though
and does that offend you if i say that
no i mean they're you know they are kind
of like my babies but yeah no no i don't
mean like that but you know what i'm
saying like
to me because i actually went jogging
this morning and i go jogging on this
around this lake and there's a lot of
turkeys out there not this time of year
actually but usually there's a lot of
turkeys out there and they're just big
and they're
they're just not the most attractive you
know they're not a peacock but right you
know yeah
i don't know they're pretty majestic for
the most part it's probably just
beauties in the eye of the beholder for
the most part some people love turkeys
love the way they look a lot of my
buddies are turkey hunters so they're
all about getting every every species of
turkey on it and mount it and
displayed as wall art for you know their
memory of that hunt yeah
and they like eating them too they're
delicious um
i don't know but you you kind of figure
they probably were at some point some
type of raptor
if you go back to dinosaurs maybe
they've just devolved yeah they grew a
little fur got a little smaller claws
but they still try to cut you yeah
if they get a chance um how sharp is
that talon how bad could that thing get
you or not oh yeah i mean i've had them
where they cut through my pants i sent
uh sent some pictures over
where they've gotten me uh
in the leg
in the back i mean they they're
with our turkeys we don't have spurs
so so they'll have those at the hatchery
they'll have them nip and so we really
don't get messed up but their front
calls you know when they jump up they're
jumping up with their feet to latch on
okay you can see that yeah see that's a
scar from there look i got some cam haze
boots to save my toes but oh yeah
but the rest of you you need that full
cam haze yeah i know he needs to come
out with some leggings or something for
me
pants or something
so that's one turkey talent did that to
you now what does their talons look like
what is their le what does that leg look
like let's see
the foot
okay
the one that's spread out you see
see they got these toenails and that's
what's got that's that's what cut me one
of those toenails
oh wow so they have so they have a spur
ours are docked so they won't have that
long spur like on a wild turkey they'll
be there but it'll be nubbed off
because they cut them off yeah so you
don't want that in there because they'll
kill each other they'll be murdering
like all sorts wow i wouldn't even go
through there at a point if they were
like that
but uh now there's claws and like i said
you'll you'll see turkeys you got videos
of turkeys fighting out in the
wilderness same thing just bigger bird
they're going to jump up at you
uh they'll try to get you i mean i've
had them pecked me in the forehead
working on feed line getting motors put
back on
they can uh and do they seem
manipulative what do turkeys seem like
as a very nice at first yeah so you know
they're like hey what's up you could be
sitting there and they'll kind of come
up and you can you know pet them on the
head
and then just next thing you know they
turn around run around and say yo john
look at this and then i'll [ __ ]
hammer you
yeah
so it's if you can work in twos a lot of
times like i said i've been doing this
so long by myself some of these repairs
and i mean they'll pick
motor lines everything where i have to
go and replace electrical
um they'll break water lines down where
they'll rip the line tear the water up i
got to get in there before it floods the
barn i mean they can they can be
destructive does it seem calculated
though does it seem like they have it
does yeah so we take every measure when
we go through retiring the blinds making
sure
if there's a will there's a way a turkey
will definitely [ __ ] something up but
does their will seem to be that they
want to create anarchy does it seem that
they want to escape like where they want
to no they you can literally leave the
door open they won't go nowhere oh i see
they'll just chill out maybe poke the
head out they're just kind of like
what's up but i think it's more like uh
you're kind of like fresh meat in prison
style you walk in there they're like
well i'm gonna get you boy oh damn yeah
after uh now this is after like 17 18
weeks they're coming at you yeah yeah
they're right they got they got their
testosterone up they don't know hormones
going they're getting crazy so their
testosterone raises while they're in
there yeah so you take their baby bird
and then they become essentially a
teenager so they got that teenager and
now they grow other birds for breeding
purposes where they'll get real big 75
80 pounds will be less birds in there
and i've i've never been to a farm like
that i've seen them and they say that
once they get over that 19 20 week range
like 22 weeks
their testosterone goes back down and
then they like mellow back out
but you're you're riding right around
that nine to 18 19 weeks
you got a good four weeks of you know
battling just trying to get through
there make sure everybody's good not
not getting getting yourself tore up so
you know it gets a little hip managed in
that last month yeah so i mean
i've had a guy one of my buddies mark
straight got drilled in the nuts we had
a i was watching him crawl out of the
barn like it took him out took him out
and you're talking about a force of a 40
pound bird and it just nut tagged him
perfect
he was laying on the ground he's trying
to get the birds are jumping on yeah you
kind of always get a fear like something
happened you get crippled in there they
probably just kill you what's a great
question we got coming up right here
about how many birds
yo what up theo what up turkey farmer
it's alex here fenton michigan
um just really got a couple quick ones
for you
uh did the turkeys have large talons
and if they do or or if they don't
um how many do you think it would take
to uh to take one of you down
gang gang gang baby thank you brother
yeah yeah how many turkeys did it take
really to take out a robert hutman man i
don't know probably
10 000 or so really i mean unless i
stroke out or something in there they
might get me but uh you know but it
looked like the damage that one could
cause is pretty extensive yeah yeah no
they uh i guess it's just all in the
right right way they get you anybody
getting knocked out by anybody for the
most part so
you know i could be leaning over and one
whacked me in a noggin and if you go out
in there that's just that's they're
gonna get you on the ground
so they're more yeah they so they might
go around and they they're just curious
so they peck right you know you might
say you struck out fall down that they
peck you i'd imagine if no one found you
for a few hours probably wouldn't be
good right straight up
so you run it with some real it's a
really
it's same as these cat ladies and [ __ ]
that died with
cats and get eaten up sitting in a chair
dude we had a lady in my neighborhood
growing up they had uh a panther in her
she had a panther live in her place
nobody everybody always thought she was
crazy always yelling about this cat
outside
and people were like get back in your
house you know and uh she had a [ __ ]
bobcat or pant or something had a big
daddy
been living in her house and she's been
in there living with it for years man
and everybody's just like you're crazy
miss dorothy you know go back inside
and uh
somebody threw a surprise party by our
house or something and somebody jumped
out and yelled surprising that damn cat
[ __ ] almost killed the guy damn
serious [ __ ]
i mean it's just you don't know you know
you don't know really what's going on
nothing inside of some of these animals
that's really the tricky part for me
yeah um is there is there a time where
you get a real big one and you're like
oh i got to pull this one out because
this one i gotta use for breed and this
one is goes somewhere else does that
ever happen or at this point you know
exactly no no we're getting into the
perfect genetics for for the birds to
create uh you know solid breast meat
we're really going for a heavier bird
for breast and uh
and thigh so we can feed feed america
trying to get back and uh
that's why we're always revolving and
just constant constant birds year round
so
how has the meat damn that's you right
there yeah damn so that's when they're
that's your first wife
yeah this is damn beautiful pretty good
yeah
that's actually when they're going out
so that's a good picture see felines
raised everything's there lights are on
it's nighttime that's one of the heavier
birds that he probably weighed close to
only 46 47 pounds and this is only a
middle tom right no this is a heavy
thomas oh this is heavy that's that's
big boy's there that's that see they got
little beards whatnot
dude it's really they're kind of
beautiful i didn't i guess i haven't
seen pictures like this yeah they're
nice pretty white birds and uh really
clean like i said the
that's why we do litter quality we're in
there tilling day to day operation every
week we go in there with a tractor and a
tiller to make sure the you know the
shavings get brought back to the top
everything stays nice for their feet
because if you've got poor litter
quality and poor life these birds won't
look like that they'll be uh
we really run down they'll have burned
pads on their feet from the turkey
turkey crap it'll burn their feet so
that's why yeah that's why we make sure
everything's nice and nice and clean so
they're a real sensitive animal huh they
can be yeah
it's interesting how they're tough and
you know turkeys are smart and dumb all
at the same time guess just like me yeah
me too dude
damn i didn't know it's possible and
then here we are
[Laughter]
um
what's something that i wouldn't expect
about a turkey man
what's something that's really unique
about them compared to maybe any other
animal is there something that really
stands out about them because they
definitely look really different they
definitely they kind of seem like a
peacock that's been
you know
essentially a peacock is a turkey just
just a different you know they're very
very similar but they'll get hooks too
they'll get spurs
they just got a
weirder uh
call than a turkey does and then
um i don't know they're characteristics
i mean they're pretty much you know
noble noble animal they they stick
together
um
i don't know just
i've been around them for so long you
know taking my i was raised raised up in
it 89 i was like five years old when my
parents started it so your parents
started this business yeah
my mom and dad did it mom worked at the
bank dad worked down the road driving
heavy equipment for a company down in
northern virginia and he would commute
like two hours back and forth and
we just needed to figure out a better
way to
to bring some money in for the farm
because the farm i actually live on
hazard mill farms it's uh been in the
family since you know
continuously since the late 1700s
and then we've been operating my great
great grandfather bought it in 1888 from
another family member and he bought a
bunch of these tracks up and he owned
both sides of the river now my other
family owns the other side we got this
side
right on the shenandoah river and has it
always been turkeys for both sides or no
no we we
my parents were the so i guess i'd be a
second generation turkey part but i mean
we did beef cattle my great grandfather
would forge the river and bring cattle
over there they did tomatoes for the
cannon factory
he was a
big time farmer granted we were poor
and lived off the land but they uh
now i mean i'm looking at
some uh
prime real estate that i just happened
to put in the conservation easements i
think i worry about the development it's
all bordered by national forests
right on the river yeah right on the
river oh wow it's beautiful yeah so do
do uh
so you guys at what point did you guys
get out of cropping and just get into uh
turkeys so we were just on beef cattle
my dad started uh started back bringing
beef back on he married in to the my
mom's side and it's my mom my
grandmother my aunt that ain't that
property
and
you know he started it and then they
decided said you can grow like i was
telling you instead of having to have
200 head of cattle you can make the same
money with two turkey barns that take up
14 acres wow so we're able to preserve
the land to the way we want because
we're more more mountain land it's all
up on mastodon mountain got some fields
out there we do hay and pasture
but other than that you know we couldn't
run uh
the 200 hit of cattle
to make enough liv you know make a
living right justify it so right well
this is just more economical makes more
sense for you yeah it's still you know
to start a new barn start to finish
right now if you're looking at you're
probably looking at 1.5 million per barn
really start to finish and then you're
not going to turn a profit until
i think they're saying depending when
that barn gets built 13 months to 16
months by time your first flock and
you're turning over some money so say
you sell a flock right the market's at a
decent
price how i mean can you is it can you
make a decent living i mean i used to
work on a farm i worked on soybean corn
and cotton farm in college at the end of
college and or at the end of high school
and beginning of college and
you know i didn't own anything but i saw
basically kind of how the living was and
like how like you know when there was a
bad crop there was some subsidization by
the government stuff like that so at
least you had a little bit of backup
because you were providing like uh
something
and yeah because you're probably
providing a value to amer you know
you're providing like food or whatever
it was or animal food or whatever
um what uh
what
what is it like for you guys there with
the market is it a like what can a
turkey farmer make
i'm pretty small scale compared to the
other guys so like cash flow wise you
know i'm pulling in you know roughly
depending the flock average you know you
can make it 150
you know give or take a year now and
that's not just on
and granted i'm still paying electric
you know some of that cost comes out but
we're kind of like a cooperative so we
get we we we do get uh some dividends
and stuff through that so it's not not
as bad as if i just grew for a
privatized company like you were
sharecropping or something yeah or if i
grew for like
uh butterball or something right they'll
give you uh incentives and stuff as well
if you do good for your first two years
but after that then there's no other
incentive to grow for them and then
you're already kind of locked you're
capped in at what you got and then
you're like well do i build a couple
more barns and take another chunk of
investment out so so it's 1.5 million to
start a new barn roughly if you wanted
to start one and that's and it's going
to be and that's before you start to
make any money to come in it'll be
through after your first flock is done
that's three four months yeah five
months maybe no no it's uh first flop
it's it's it's like i said 13 to 14
months
you're built you got your first flock in
and it's out the door turn around okay
and how long is that flock coming you
said it's 19 weeks 19 weeks 19 weeks
okay how much months is that almost five
months
so you can maybe do two flocks in a year
kind of is that what you kind of go for
we go three flocks a year oh you do yeah
oh because you can overlap some yeah
yeah huh do you have the idea that you
want to do another barn you think you
kind of get where you're at i'm good
where i'm at i got a
like i was telling him i'm moving i shut
down one production side and i'm
actually i've created hazmat selects
so right now we're doing cbd we're
growing hemp in there and then where
virginia just went legal for uh
marijuana so that's my whole
another step i'm getting ready to
try to get one of these permits and
go
dude if you came out with a tip with
that turkey thc that [ __ ] that'll put
you to sleep boy you know what i'm
saying dude because both those things
will put me to sleep if i have a little
bit of turkey or have a dang hit on a
joint or hit on it damn yeah just smell
you right now dab you know hell if i
even kiss some girl that's been smoking
dope i'll [ __ ] go to bed man i gotta
sleep real easy dude i'm real you know
i'm saying that i don't see you gotta
rub your belly oh dude
i see a pillow somewhere it's over yeah
you know it's time um why does why does
turkey make people go to sleep
yeah
i'm not too familiar with it but i know
they it releases some type of uh
endorphin or or whatnot but it it's
supposed to
it's kind of like a melatonin you get
from it
do turkeys sleep a lot do they have it
because it's in them i guess well
they'll they'll kind of get in that
nesting when the you know lights go out
for them they'll they'll get their
downtime and they'll kind of
rubble up and that that's when they're
all together they kind of just like to
stick together and
you'll see see them all like winged wing
just chilling out and nestled down
they'll take the fresh shavings kick it
over and then just kind of snuggle up
kind of like lines or something like if
you see a uh
lines out there yeah
um
now what are turkeys like different in
the wild so do you turkey hunt also yeah
i'm a habit hunter fisherman outdoorsman
yeah
um
pretty much the same except for that
they're able to they're not as heavy so
they'll fly up and roost every night so
they'll do the same thing but they'll
roost in trees together
okay um how high can a turkey get up in
a tree
i've seen them up in pine trees 20 20 to
30 feet no way then they'll come off
that roost and just glide i mean if
they're off off a canyon or a little
cliff style they'll just glide over and
go like three or four hundred yards and
then just poop and then they start doing
doing turkey things start pecking and
looking for food and scratching around
i've actually had turkeys come up to my
barns and get them riled up where
they're gobbling back and forth at each
other during spring time
outside like what's up and then they
just start going back and forth
and who fights more than males or female
turkeys
the males yeah females you know other
than if something's trying to get after
their babies they generally
in the wild they don't right yeah what
keeps them from mating when they're in
uh
y'all's uh containment
over there i think it's just because
they're not technically a mature bird oh
so they're not even at what age do they
start to mate like right about right
when they're getting ready to go out so
they don't really
you know
so a lot of them are never going to see
fatherhood really no no well they just
get their uh
you know do their job and
you know feed america it's uh it's
entertainment hey everybody i mean it's
uh
is there a lot of pushback on the
industry
no not i wouldn't say for it's such a
staple see turkeys you know we're not
like chicken companies so you know
they're we're a little more of a niche
market compared to like purdue for their
chickens because you know you're not
seeing turkey chicken nuggets you ain't
seen turkey nuggets right inside so the
demand's so high for chicken that they
have have a larger turnaround and then
there you know there's instances where
you see some some bad stuff that happens
on farm with other workers and stuff
like that but
how did how did y'all lose that battle
was there like a battle where it was
like chicken or turkey was gonna be the
excite the one the new the thing you
know
i don't know man they've been growing uh
turkey since like the 50s and 60s in the
shenandoah valley where i'm from and
um i don't think it was ever uh
i guess it was something back in the day
because i guess turkeys got stapled as a
thanksgiving
you know niche and then
you think i'm gonna eat turkey once a
year maybe christmas you know yeah so
you're like okay i'll eat my turkey and
then just eat chicken the rest of the
time yeah yeah so i think maybe we kind
of got ourselves put into the
first thanksgiving put us here yeah
people get tired eat that big meal you
get tired and you're like oh i'm good on
turkey for a while
yeah maybe that's part of it too maybe
turkey has that thing where it's like
i'm gonna um i'm a holiday
vibe yeah
i think it's true it's like it's been
romanticized kind of in culture as yeah
like a holiday meat special like yeah
it's a fancy thing you would see rich
people like get a thing and they got a
big uh plaque or something they're
eating off of and they're you know
somebody's rich and the kid's on pills
or whatever but he's still laughing
like it's all you know like the norman
rockwell or something you'd see those
pictures and i think it makes you have a
full turkey a full-size pig with an
apple stuck in yeah yeah yeah king's
table like king's law yeah yeah you
would see that you're like oh man this
is a fancy turkey leg oh yeah somebody
um
here's a question that came in right
here from christopher right here let's
get to it
hey theo mr turkey farmer this is chris
from down in sydney australia
rise obliged rise up like
i was just uh wondering i'm a big fan of
turkey i think it's a great meat it's
nourishing it's lean
and i just wondered why you don't see it
on more fast food chains like at
mcdonald's or kfc
because you know me i'd love to have a
gobble gobble
uh no homo yeah yeah it's good yeah but
yeah that's my question why don't you
see turkey on more fast food menus
because it's a great great meat yeah it
is
gang baby thank you bro
and uh rise up lights if you say razer
if you say rise up lights
rise up lights a couple times
it sounds like razor blades in australia
okay
rise up lights you just taught me
something there yeah try it it rise up
lights
rise up lights up lights yeah it sounds
like razor blades razor so anyway just
good ice breaker good you know keep the
wife warm with that one
but that's a great question yeah how
does it why isn't it do you think it's
headed that way well first start why
isn't it and why isn't turkey more that
thing now you do see it at like a jimmy
john's you do see
subways you see it at orbeez
um so you're seeing like a lot of them
it's going to be like the sliced turkey
so that's something that we would
probably sell like a product where
they're getting that breast meat to the
masses i'd love to see like a
turkey tender instead of a chicken
tender
i just think the market for it to be
sustainable like that the reason you
haven't seen the turkeys go hard
um it's just really just
the we don't have that type of
that many farmers out there to actually
be able to consistently sustain that
that demand at the moment so it's kind
of like we go all in and then
say you guys don't end up wanting to you
know turkey nuggets or whatnot and then
then you got like a lot of farmers
don't invest you know two three million
dollars in this stuff and then they're
out out on the streets again you almost
need a different hype man you need like
a big pr thing to be like turkey is that
thing it's like because you see us at
panera bread that's another big comp oh
yeah yeah
yeah it's interesting i hadn't really
thought like it's only turkey is often
sliced or you see it at like a boston
market or something like that sometime a
place where they do more of a meal
i think yeah it's regarded as more of a
meal and not as much of a i don't want
to say like a cheap eat but
because i love turkey burgers turkey
burgers is something i love delicious
that's great man so
and maybe some of it's growing over time
do you know if the market is growing
over time um it has compared i mean
you're going from you know when my
parents started in 89
i know i know they've had some attempts
niche markets where they pushing it but
now since people are more
wanting to know what they put in their
body like he was saying people want that
lean protein from that turkey and it's
different than chicken yeah i think it's
if not better i mean you barbecue up a
couple a couple chicken tenders and
slice that breast up just right i mean
oh it's good on the grill good good
anywhere man [ __ ] looks good man yeah
god damn it looks good you know i'm
thinking about it right now dude if i
had it i'd cook it for you [ __ ] man
at the end
people see you they just want some damn
turkey like yeah what are you doing here
give me something
it's like hey man can i get another
[Laughter]
you know
is one part is there a part of the
turkey that's being used for something
new and novel that we're that we don't
know about or like a new
like is there a part that they're using
they sell everything from our turkeys to
everything yeah the the feathers will go
you know they they've even shipped stuff
to south korea stuff like that
the guts the in-ear stuff like that i
don't know what they use them for but
they've found a really good market where
they can you know be very useful and use
pretty much all the birds the feet what
you know huh so there's a niche for just
about anything in the world somebody's
going to eat it like we were just
talking about turkey fries you wouldn't
think that would be a niche but we sell
a pile of turkey fries
and what is it oh a turkey fries and nut
nuts yeah turkey damn
you haven't had that
you know two out of three men two-thirds
of men will experience uh some form of
hair loss
oh the other day i saw a guy watching a
scary movie and his damn mustache fell
right off
right onto the damn remote dear god
well keeps offers a simple stress free
way to keep your hair convenient virtual
doctor consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months
you don't have to leave your home low
cost treatments start at just ten
dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com slash theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash t-h-e-o get your
first month free
it's a great gift for someone
they're struggling with hair loss so
they're worried or if you are treat
yourself
keeps dot com
slash
theo
you know my favorite pair of sweats
have become my dang favorite pair of
business attire
these days with the world where it is
you people are doing business from a
damn bunker in their backyard
you see a dude doing damn business and
he's on a damn uh
and he's doing um
kegels and chest exercises with his
buddies in the park
times have changed
yup it's ridiculous that i got to change
if i'm running for a coffee or if i'm
running for an actual run
it shouldn't be that way
that's why you got to check out public
wreck
they make elevated
athleisure
wear hey
in multi-dimensional sizes jeeps
because they believe that comfort starts
with a better fit
their best-selling all-day everyday pant
is available in over 40 different sizing
combinations and can fit men anywhere
from five eight to nearly seven feet
tall dang that's drastic measures dang
they come in nine different colors one
for each day of the week and you could
do two weekends
if something happened to the week of the
second week
public wreck also makes elevated shorts
t-shirts polos jackets even golf gear
they've got it all
public wreck rarely discounts but right
now they have an exclusive offer just
for tpw listeners go to publicrec.com
and use promo code theo to receive 10
percent off that's publicrec rec.com
and use promo code theo for 10
off public wreck yourself
um what else we got over there spence
anything else come in here's a question
right here from a white guy
what up theo it's carl out here in
milwaukee wisconsin shout out nick uh i
have a quick question for your turkey
farmer uh what does he eat on
thanksgiving
because for me if i was processing all
those birds and and getting ready for
this thanksgiving rush i'd be so over it
i'd be like no we're gonna get some
steaks we're gonna get some ham or
something something else um so what does
he do and then if he is turkey then
what's his favorite side because
obviously the birdman is going to know
the best side to go with some turkey
so i'm looking for some suggestions
appreciate you
yeah birdman yeah what's the uh what is
it what's the choice from the captain
himself what what is it
you know i always joke around with the
guys with the company we eat one of our
turkeys every year so like just before i
come here one of my guys from the
company we kill kill our own birds and
then we keep keep our turkey birds and
we give everybody and the company a free
turkey okay but with that being said i i
mean i've been lobbying to to get some
ham maybe partner up with a
pig company or a
check exchange or something yeah y'all
do is there any dark you sneaking over
there at night across the freaking pig
pen or what is there any no no it's not
that uh but do you choose so for
thanksgiving you guys have turkey yes i
i i mean i cook a lot of them you know
borderline chef
wife's a chef but uh we
we do the i do a nice infrared so i
don't deep fried but i put them in that
infrared and it gets that crispiness
just like a deep fried bird without all
that oil really is that the new thing
that's delicious is it yeah because i
grew up on that turducken man and even
though i answered
damn uh
i remember it's like a turkey and a duck
and then they fill it with cheetos i
remember [ __ ] and i'm like what is this
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying the head
damn every spicy cheetos
uh i think
i couldn't tell i think it was regular
okay yeah because we nobody in our area
ate those jalapeno cheetos yeah it was
more they didn't even have the hot ones
at that point it was just
they were still doing the regular cheeto
you know something to try but that third
item now did that turducken did that
ever hit you do you guys have to do that
no no um i've never i mean i've bought a
turducken you believe in all that it's
not it's okay it's just a lot going on
you got the turkey and chicken and all
that stuff stuffed in there sometimes
i've seen them stuff a quail in that
thing yeah
or i've seen uh tyrala tarala
geep or whatever it is tur allah geep
it's turkey alligator and then sheep
meat in it
and i'm like
at some point people are just damn this
is a damn gang bang i feel like you know
what i'm saying like that's a little too
much i feel like if uh you get those all
those meats and just cook them primarily
alone and you can still do your own mix
yeah you could mix it on your plate like
why do you have to i feel like they give
robs flavor from one or the other
yeah it's a lot of trial and error there
um
now i like i like my turkey i like to do
it uh you know in that infrared deep
fryer style oilless fryer whatever you
want to do is i've never had that that
song it's almost like a sauna so it's uh
it's propane and then it's like one of
those uh smokeless fire pits
you know so now the smoke comes up and
it's like a tube and you drop the turkey
in just like a fryer and the heat just
goes around it and they crisp it up just
press oh damn yeah like that thing's in
barbados or something i like to inject
it with some marinades get it juicy
do you guys also have you ever thought
of getting into that market or that's
not really your market to get into like
a marinade it's because i guess you
don't have that store front i i right
now do not have the storefront
eventually i you know hazard bill farms
itself you know we're planning to
put in uh probably some grapes do a
winery i wanted to infuse some cbd into
my wine tasting room i got a vents barn
down there on the river we've been doing
some events
and stuff so yeah i'm curious you sound
like you have like a do you feel like
you wanted to be a turkey farmer do you
feel like you wanted to be an
entrepreneur like where do you kind of
feel like some of your sense to do to be
a businessman came from um just just
being able to diversify and uh
my major push is to save small farms be
creative and then give back so
entrepreneurship was you know all on me
setting around i want to be creative so
my daughter doesn't have to sell the
property or
i think the death of small farms is
really where the mom and dad starts to
farm we can't afford to live off them we
go get a job then we end up getting our
own career so they just never really
come back to the farm until mom and dad
dies and then boom they're celibate and
then they're selling it because their
interest is going so yeah it's
interesting how we do that huh yeah so
i'm here to you know the that's why i
came to chat i mean i'm really
i'm on uh sixth district is the con
congressional district i'm in i'm
on the ag advisory committee for
congressman klein okay and uh and that's
in virginia yeah that's in virginia so
really bad props to ben klein good
friend of mine
he really wants to know what's every net
she wants to know what's good for dairy
for his district what's good for poultry
um you know he he doesn't know much
about it because he you know he was an
attorney commonwealth attorney and then
got got the congressional uh spot there
a few years back
so i mean just i give him bad props he's
going out trying to find us like-minded
farmers to meet and then help him out
what do we need how we can do better and
how how can we save these farms and keep
keep us rocking wow
and what's the biggest threat to the
small farms
um
subdivisions and development oh really
yeah well i guess when you said that you
had that conservative ship now a
conservatorship
i got a conservation easement
yeah with vcc virginia council
um
out of uh stanton virginia so your land
will be safe now so they can't develop
within even if it sold they would have
to buy that thing in a large track and
there's no commercial nor uh housing can
be developed wow if anything did happen
yeah you know it's interesting because i
had on a guy who does small game he does
like if you got something in your house
that's not your wife or kid and it
shouldn't but it's trying to you know
yeah be alive you know what i'm saying
that mid-size animal control man yeah
this fella
and he said that a lot of times you find
raccoons in your house you understand he
goes it's because he's like they don't
know what your house dude they're not
like robbers or burglars you know like
they're not like the wet bandits you
know what i'm saying like they are just
they think it's a tree like their trees
have all been torn down and [ __ ] so
they're just climbing into whatever
seems like it's close to that so it's
interesting when we start to really
give up our nature um
i think a lot of it goes too too we get
so stuck inside of ourselves like i was
going for a jog this morning it's
beautiful out there man and that's the
place where i seen the wild turkeys they
just have them out there and like you
see them gobbling and something they'll
be a little crew i'm pretty cool just
just to run right i mean you're probably
15 20 feet and sometimes they're they
run off sometime they'd be a little
curious but
so it's like but it's i'm sometimes i'm
so in my head the whole time i'm running
i'm barely even seeing that i'm in like
a damn
beautiful place you know i mean it's
stunning so i'm missing
all of the uh
i'm missing all of the nature i think a
lot of that kind of stuff happens
because we just don't we don't even
value it anymore we don't even see it
yeah you know
um anyway that's a long diatribe for me
but so so one of the big biggest
problems is people coming along and just
building stuff yeah
yeah so like i said as soon as that
family loses interest and i you can't
blame the kid that went out and started
a nice career somewhere else i get it
but if if we're able to
diversify agritourism is huge for us
right now that's kind of what i'm what
i'm doing with the i want to do the
grapes the wine cbd eventually cannabis
you know i just want to be able to have
a
good living with the wedding venue and
events venue that i'm doing right now
it's been a big hit done a lot of
charity work this past year with it
so it's give back to the community why
we you know try to preserve
this you know beautiful piece of track
of land i got and uh
just that whole valley we i'm very
fortunate not only my property i mean we
we have a whole corridor on that river
that's all under conservation easement
now on the shenandoah valley can you
bring that up yeah south fork of the
shenandoah river
um and i think it's interesting that uh
you know because it is interesting if
you're doing events and
when i saw those pictures of the white
can you show me the pit to the picture
of you in there without those white
birds
it's funny it really changed a lot of my
perception of what i was even
talking about because i just don't have
any idea a lot of people have you just
have no idea yeah you don't you don't
know the market it's not a very uh
you've never seen anything yeah that's
me right there shadow river oh that's
beautiful man
yeah we got the uh that's so that's a
view
from andy gatz go down a little bit that
right there shando state park that's
in
so that's a view back going toward my
mountain okay that's uh my family across
the river there uh my great uncle put
that and sold that to the state park to
save it from being developed wow so it's
andy gas state park it's really
i mean i'm not trying to be biased but i
think we have probably the prettiest
stretch of river in the whole valley but
uh it goes all the way up to paige and
leray and they'll it'll run all the way
to harpers ferry all the way up to in
tennessee west virginia harpers ferry oh
wow yeah it flows north so go all the
way down dump into a potomac so front
royal they'll run in that's our town we
live in north and south meet
and then that shenandoah river becomes
one the john denver stuff
then you'll go on down and it'll join in
harper's ferry and dump into the potomac
wow i just we did a set of soak i always
go along the potomac i never knew what
it was i mean i knew about it yeah but
it's uh
yeah it's just funny we just i mean i
don't know i don't say we but i need to
see more nature so that it becomes a you
know more of a common understanding
anytime you want to come out take you
fishing i see you called smallmouth
there a while back oh yeah dude barely
caught it jesus
but it was pretty cool we were catching
um the minnows minnows yeah literally
out of like if we had like one of those
nets you throw it yeah
it was so cool i've never done it so
then you you get it on the thing and
then you put it in this other thing in
this other area where the water is water
and then next thing you know you get a
uh oh dude they were like hammering it
but after about
32 minutes 31 minutes they quit i think
that word got out
yeah
they you got so many in one hole they
get gigs get up but yeah yeah anytime uh
you come on out to the river man we'll
take you up what's the city that's near
you guys so front royal blue ray that's
kind of rural uh front row where the
gateway is skyline drive and that's the
start and skyline drive will go all the
way down to stanton and it turns into
the blue ridge parkway it goes north
carolina okay um but winchester i know
you've probably heard of winchester
winchester virginia yeah no so that's
the next one up and then we're only like
70 miles from dc okay yeah
yeah man i wouldn't mind coming to check
out the turkey farm maybe on a tour
whenever we do
dc
we could set it up because we just went
to richmond
but
um
i'm sure we'll go somewhere else but
yeah it's just funny man until i saw
that picture of you with those i'm like
i didn't even know they looked like this
i don't have a real
perception of something
um what's another question that came in
uh
here for robert uh spence
oh shoot gotta turn that around
what up theo what up turkey killer
uh i know theo you know he believes in
it and uh certain people like to debate
it but i want to know if there's ever
been a turkey with that ds
you know you've seen one with one eye
open or cross-eyed or whatever
um
curious to see if you ever seen one and
do those kind of get kicked out from the
rest of the group as far as what gets
put on thanksgiving dinner table or what
uh
let me know all right gang gang turkey
hitter gang baby yeah do turkeys get
diseases like humans do they get down
syndrome they'll have some modified
genetics every once while like a crooked
foot or you know
just like a droopy neck or
it's not so much like what we call it
like down syndrome i just think it's you
know they're born with some type of
disability and uh
usually they get called out just uh
nature yeah man you either uh you don't
want that bird to suffer in it it's like
i said depending on the bird
like one guy asked if we ever kind of
keep him i do have like a a holding pin
to help birds heal back up and if they
can make it they can that way they're
not in general population yeah yeah kind
of yeah yeah get them out of gin
put them in that solitaire but uh
but now we you know we're we're just
trying to run a a healthy
successful business hopefully and
but yeah they just get cold man some
sometimes it's a dog eat world out there
yeah it's andrew it's funny how we we
romanticize
nature as if it's gonna do this
beautiful thing for itself
that once we become involved that like
oh well
um
of course sometimes we're using animals
for food of course but
but also it's like
you know
like a raccoon will kill its children a
raccoon a man raccoon will kill a female
raccoon's children just so she'll go
back into heat so we can have sex same
with the bear i mean that's some damn
that's i mean that's some lesser whole
[ __ ] yeah you know what i'm saying dude
that's dark arts yeah so you know being
being ethical
and uh properly euthanizing them
on the spot you know you got to make
that call and not even second guess i
mean
cam talks the same stuff about how you
know
cruel the hunting you know the nature is
compared to honey and it's true i mean
you you're able to
you know arrow that that animal or you
know shoot that animal at a
good ethical shot and you're able to
harvest that meat with you know minimum
damage where you you watch a
wilder beast or whatever out there
getting eaten by a line while he's just
sitting there with a broken back
hollering same with the bears and it's
just yeah they're not doing it athlete
it's not like they're inviting them to a
damn holiday inn or they eat them while
they're still alive
so it's like man come on
it's interesting that whole that whole
world is interesting you know um we had
the guy jimmy john who uh john liatau
who who ran the jimmy you created the
jimmy john's company right
we were talking a little bit he's a big
game hunter and
but what some people don't know is that
you pay sometimes exorbitant fees to go
hunt like a specific animal and then the
fee will uh
pay for like the
yeah we'll pay for like local school i
mean especially like when you're in
africa some of these other countries
like you're paying for like you're gonna
really keep that economy alive and it
provides that food for that that
community i mean oh yeah there's tons of
things that go into that yeah that's
true the food too yeah conservation is
key because they
they have those villagers come and
actually i have a friend that's south
african and they you know his family had
a hunting preserve he moved to my town
but
same thing man they're they're there to
feed the the village and they got like
100 little they they watch out for uh
poachers they'll notify the oh yeah you
know they're there to snitch on these
you know awful people that are poachers
and
you know that's their livelihood yeah
it's their future that's what keeps them
surviving yeah so it's interesting it's
like wendy it's like yeah what is you
like
that whole line is very interesting um
do you feel like turkeys seem like a
regular pet do they seem like a dog do
they seem like they have that kind of
thing in them or do they seem
more distant and more like just a snack
i mean there's a there's a fine balance
if you
i don't care if that turk you had two
turkeys by themselves and a pen that you
farm-raised your
they can kind of you know they can get
to the point where they're kind of
a little bit nicer but like i said they
the the people that are raising turkeys
small small range and backyard
um at a point at that 18 to 19 old range
they're still going to be an [ __ ]
right but like i said as they get older
that stuff goes away they they'll mellow
out right now i've seen turkeys that are
pretty chilled and cool
and then i've seen turkeys that are you
know it's probably just like human
nature you know we some of us are
chilled and others are complete dicks oh
dude most i mean when i was 16 years old
i was probably deserved to die yeah i
mean if i'm really in the same house
everybody i know did uh what's the
personal life like over there you got a
spouse i see you brought your beautiful
wife here today uh
where'd you guys meet
oh we met uh at a bar
yeah yeah
you gotta when y'all were how what age
were you oh i think i was
mid-20s by then so
yeah i think we've been together for
about eight years
so that's a nice run huh
how's it been when you give him a thumbs
up so far she puts up with me does she
yeah she's a good girl did she want to
be a entrepreneur does she have a
business side or is that yeah yeah so
she she uh she she came from the
restaurant industry chef ran a
restaurant there in town for a while we
got together i built her a food truck
she was chefing up some some quality
food at a couple wineries we do some big
events like cycle virginia where there's
like not only 35 3 800 cyclists oh wow
and then uh we do other events and then
now she's doing uh tiny hazard uh kids
clay she we have a daughter that's five
years old and she makes some really uh
unique pieces for for
other moms they got a bunch of different
moms groups and stuff they so she's a
homemaker she's making uh making awesome
awesome clothes and
it's called tiny hazards
okay cool yeah we'll share the website
and stuff and share the link and so
that's a small business and that's what
kind of stuff would you get from there
could you get stuff for the holiday
season from there yeah yeah she's
getting ready i think you got a whole
holiday
line you're doing so she's got the
christmas collection there you go yeah
and it's for children's clothing yeah
yeah so snow for kids
i'm sure she would make something for
some animals some dogs and cats but
she's got her template uh done and
she'll do uh from babies up to toddlers
so
it's kind of like that i don't know if
you ever heard of rags but that's kind
of kind of like a kid's clothes like
that but it's raining
nice now i'm gonna have to check it out
i don't have any children yet but i
wouldn't mind getting a wife and getting
some children well you're in nashville
there's plenty of them down there i know
man
a lot of them down there are getting
damn dui's you know saying i gotta find
one i think a little
further away from broadway where there's
a little less lick around yeah well
you're good over here you probably get
your suburban i got a yeah maybe one
with some more antibiotics in it yeah
get you a farm girl
i wouldn't mind you know one with like
you know something in kentucky with
horse farm or something yeah
i wouldn't mind you know sometimes i
wonder why like uh
you definitely find it you definitely
find more of like kind of a hunt not i
don't want to say homemaker type but
people that there's people that's more
family-centric i think here yeah um in
like los angeles there it's a little bit
more work-centric and
it's hard to have a family because
everybody kind of that's part of a
family but it's hard to have like a
space yeah for a family to really like
breathe i think well it's good to get
that teammate she does you know she does
she's not just at home she works for a
successful barbecue company she does all
the bookkeeping
tax preparation same with me she keeps
my
my books in order so i don't have to
think as much yeah
on that i feel you taxes taxes are the
devil
thinking's a damn devil dude
that's trouble yeah it is trouble man um
and what's the biggest threat then to
turkey crops every year
um just just the unknown
avian flu or something like lightning or
something
no lightning's not a big deal
no we're good it was that i mean that
you you can have pileups
if loud noises or go out but like i said
we got alarm systems in there we know
what that stuff's running at all i mean
if something happened i get a phone call
right now and on the send my worker in
there
um the bigger operations oh they'll have
like a whole command center and they'll
have cameras on every every angle
computers run the it's like pumped yeah
man computers computers run the curtain
machines the heaters everything's on
thermostat everything and we're trying
to provide them with the best possible
growing environment and that's pretty
much you know as long as you don't mess
up with the biosecurity and go in there
and bring something from the outside
world you're
usually golden
now they a lot of there's a lot of like
uh
hypo i mean even with that avian flu or
whatever flu yeah and humans can get
that too
now that's not transmitted from from
what i uh you know what we've read on
that that's not something there's a type
of avian flu that will go transfer to
human
but i think all that stuff's over in
china and uh can we transfer anything to
them is there any like illness that you
would have or not have you said let's
don't do it today no nothing uh that we
carry would you know
transcend over there i mean they had uh
i think some turkeys had what they call
like a blue comb it's kind of like a
coronavirus
but they that's something that's been
for years they've had and it's just kind
of similar symptoms other than you they
get like a kind of a cough chill out for
about two weeks it's just like a little
flu
but it's not you know it does hurt their
growth but it doesn't really like
massively kill them but i've heard of
stuff like that out there but you know
for the most part in the valley we've
done very well and we're spaced out
enough and we create
you know good good quality birds and
uh
another little statistic i didn't even
hit you with just
just the industry alone for poultry in
virginia you know that's that's a 12 to
billion dollar industry wow
that we provide
wow
so it's not like it's small time i mean
we're a small time but we're providing a
much larger service than what we yeah
yeah you don't think about it i mean
people just think everything just comes
from somewhere people think you just get
emailed to turkey now like it's just you
know yeah
um
one last question i had why can't why do
we cannot have turkey eggs it's the same
as chicken eggs yeah no way
yeah yeah it's a bigger bigger egg i
didn't know it
it's bigger too it's a little bit bigger
and does it taste the same
i mean it's not too much different i've
only had it a few times but i mean
you could potentially get turkey eggs if
you had like a
a laying operation like a small time
and it's i believe i don't even know
anybody right now that does that you
know like from a small farm aspect like
you know everybody has some chickens or
something yeah and they produce
you get three chickens they're producing
way more eggs than you could ever eat by
yourself oh yeah my sister they am
eating there you got eggs everywhere
they're dying eggs they're dying eggs on
them you know they're dying them for
halloween and [ __ ] they're out of their
minds but
uh but yeah they got i love their that
when they have chickens i love being
over there some of the chickens get
pretty friendly yeah some some will
some uh usually them roosters like i
said just like a turkey [ __ ] yeah
coming up trying to throw throw bows on
you so turkey's a bit more like a
rooster yeah okay so that's concept you
know how roosters can be really
aggressive chase you them turkeys will
chase you
i wonder some of these kind of more like
athletic type men's and stuff we do a
chicken a turkey egg i wonder if there'd
be a market for that like
i feel like if i'm a protein you know
like i'm one of those guys then i'd love
to have me you know eight turkey eggs at
the house have the boys come over yeah i
don't i mean i think some of them guys
they go for ostrich eggs you see how big
they suckers oh really yeah let me see a
turkey egg
spence
and we'll get out of here
i never even looked at one
yeah oh damn yeah
see
it's a handful
that's bigger than a chicken egg yeah
yeah
that's bigger than a jumbo chicken egg
at that you see all the whole palm of
the hand so you're looking at maybe a
regular eggs like that and then i like
that there you go oh stunting and he's
mixed too that one uh-huh got that
speckle yeah boy damn
that ben simmons baby let's go son
um
what do you do to keep busy outside of
uh when you're not working
uh about
close nine ten years ago i started doing
brazilian jiu jitsu did you yeah yeah
and then uh
been been doing it ever since started a
gym
now i got two gyms located at one in
front royal one in lee ray
my other buddies uh second degree black
belt uh my buddy andy he's got a
gentleman harrisonburg near jmu college
and oh yeah so we started starting
conference i think yeah they're going
big time they're going
good for them yeah man they're killing
it they got got a good program and
they'll bring in a lot more money with
that new
i think they're going to pack pacsun or
or json or something something like that
something something
yeah sun belt no belt i think
no belt that's my uh jiu jitsu class
yeah yeah
oh that's cool man see ron oh you also
run the gyms you have people that run
them so i run the gyms with other
instructors a couple of guys that you
know came up through the ranks with me
and uh i'm currently at brown belt right
now under uh christian woodman see and
he's a autist black belt from
his gems in philly so logic and then uh
just all over the place man i've trained
with all the autos guys jt torres andre
uh galbo and then i just had uh my buddy
nassar he's one of the hq black belts
out he came out and we had him for a
seminar hung out with him about four or
five days oh that's cool huh get some
training in and good times but
yeah andy's jim's pressure bjj and
harrisonburg but now with me i love it
my daughter is five now so she she's
always yeah she's all about it yeah it's
a great community yeah so i love the
kids class adults class we know we just
come together and have a good time
yeah it was funny i was in uh that's
awesome man and and congrats on just
staying so uh
entrepreneurial that's one thing i find
that's always interesting in people is
how do you get entrepreneurial you know
how where does that come from i just i
think uh
you know certain
certain drives you know i'm not i'm not
working a typical nine to five job like
yourself you're not doing you know
you're doing your thing grinding it out
and
um i'm always taking on you know i get
get a bunch of crap but you know she she
supports me on everything i do but i do
take on a lot of projects you know i'm
doing
thermal shelter i'm building a homeless
shower trailer right now um for animals
or people for people for the thermal
shelter for the homeless here in my town
uh homeless how many people live in the
town it's not like you probably have
it's like 11 homeless yeah it's probably
like you probably get about 25 or so oh
that's fair then yeah we got a
population of 40 50 000 people oh wow
that's a nice size so it's not not too
bad we get a lot of dc people move out
and it's a pretty place to live i bet
huh it's gorgeous mountains uh rivers
there you got i mean
the tourism aspect there you know that
we had uh we call them leafers they just
come there to skyline drive they want to
see they want to see the leaves and
you're talking about they're backed all
the way back up 66
for miles yeah it'll mess up it turns
our traffic into uh
495 baltimore style traffic for for
those few weekends
of the year yeah we were just riding
through like uh
vermont and some other places and the
best part we got a tour bus for the
first time rented a tour bus
yeah it was real interesting but i got
to sit in the back and have the window
open it's like man you just get to see
the lee we're just cruising through leaf
areas you know
you see all these leaf people and like
the wife's got you know the shirt made
just completely out of the she's got all
these leaves hooked on her shirt yeah
damn scarecrow you'll see them yank off
side of the red about run you off just
get a picture they're like i'm going to
take a picture
yeah every five miles new pitcher
is there like an albino turkey that
happens is there any like interesting
pigmentation that happened with a rare
bird where you get a completely white or
black or no blue turkey is there
anything interesting like that no our
birds are you know a nicholas or a
hybrid style bird and they're always
going to be a white white feathered bird
and
nothing
nothing out of the norm now wild turkeys
you have different
subspecies and they'll crossbreed mainly
you know out west where the marionette
marion and the rio kind of
pops out a hybrid looking bird right but
uh
you ever eaten peacock or anything like
that i won't say nothing
no i ain't ain't no peacock i thought
about that yeah i am
[Laughter]
i've thought about it i will eat some
one day i'm just gonna be honest yeah so
i don't want to say i'm nodding a lot
everybody that's good stuff right here i
hear good things yeah look i mean look
it's a bird yeah
look if it looks like that i'm gonna
have a little
that's all i'm saying um robert up man
thank you so much for being here with us
man i really appreciate it i definitely
appreciate it oh i got you some swag
from the farm in the jiu jitsu gym oh i
need a new hat so i got that uh it's a
brand build
all my stuff yeah they're cool company
huh yeah man they do
awesome work
they do they've been doing real well
they sent us something a while back nice
of them
how's your meal from there's a farm yeah
that's the farm there you hang baby
there's an extra medium you find your
extra video i've never seen that
you got a medium there if you find your
girl down there okay
so what's up i got the turkey i like
them baby you know
you know how i like them dude at least
16 weeks yeah
yes sir uh robert huffman thank you so
much for coming in dude this is really a
just a nice gift man i know with with uh
thanksgiving time people aren't thinking
about turkeys and stuff do native
americans ever look at you as like the
bad like do you ever get billed as like
the bad guy for doing turkey thing
that's in my face i mean i got some
native american family members so we're
the the virginia tribes they they still
give a uh a turkey and a deer to the
governor every year oh wow but uh no
really yeah it's pretty remarkable if
you look that up they'll still do that
uh
um it's like an annual since there's no
reservations or anything in virginia you
know there's just
what's left of us in the that area you
know my uh family members they do the
pow wows and they'll do nate uh you have
native american family members yes i got
some that are married in and you know
they uh they treat me you know they're
awesome so i mean
i don't have uh
i don't think they're really worried
about nobody's coming at you like you're
like pilgrim no no yeah i didn't think
no you never know what's going on out
there man you never know but yeah
everybody's everybody's kosher with me i
try to
do my thing help people
do good stuff yeah it sounds like it man
yeah congrats on running a cool small
business man and uh
and and uh in a big industry yeah and
just you know it's fascinating to learn
and how much it costs to start and yeah
it's been a real interesting conference
conversation for me man i appreciate
your time yeah i appreciate you having
me there and you know i do
tours with the 4-h kids get them
involved kind of give them that that
info on that industry and uh oh yeah my
sister has a little bunny name i don't
know what his name was uh i think his
name was denver or something but he won
they won something they keep him pretty
clean but
i wish he kept their damn house cleaner
that thing is a damn trap dog god dang
dude i said the lord ain't gonna show up
in here if this place is dirty
i said he's just not doing it you know
but
um yeah we'll put the links to some of
the stuff that you're doing man so
people can check it out um one other
thing i do a hunting uh youth day every
year for kids and like i was telling
them i take six
six kids maximum
uh from everywhere from new jersey
atlanta they come out and i partnered
with my best friend tj he's a vp of the
black american outdoorsman
they got a pretty good-sized following
and we bring them out give them all
their swag they get hunting gear it's a
black hunting group yeah like but yeah
they have america man yeah yeah it's for
everyone yeah they got some cool groups
out there dude i see on tick tock some
black hunter dudes sometimes yeah just
because i never growing up i never saw
that you know but now you see a lot more
uh i just had never seen it but anyway
yeah it's getting no man everybody loves
to hunt yeah everybody loves a lot of
people do and and the better we are at
introducing new people
um it's just going to be good for our
industry and our sport for the the
hunting aspect and the outdoors and the
main is goals try to save as much land
that we can for not only farming but
you know certain places just need to go
look at yeah we only have pictures like
that that we can pull up and and
yeah if we don't take care of certain
land you know um
it's funny because even we went and
looked in uh chattanooga a couple months
ago we were doing a show over there so
we went out to the
there you can see some of the river and
stuff there and and now there's more
factories in the distance so even the
scenery there it's just getting a little
bit more did you guys go up on the cliff
yeah we went up on one of them i don't
remember which one it was but yeah but
it's just interesting we don't think
about all that you know and
until today we do and i don't think what
turkey but it looks like it'd be a
turkey farmer so i'll see that picture
it's funny you just don't know until you
have some introduction so thank you yeah
for introducing us to some stuff today
man now i'm super excited to be here
thanks man yeah appreciate it man you
guys be well and happy thanksgiving to
you yep thanks
but when i find it i'll patch up where
it's
been blown
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
[Music]
now